klickt
willkommen bei einem kilo klar besser
und zwar zu vielen tutor hey hallo
mattel sowie beschäftigen heute im
prinzip mit der frage wie geht man als
tutorin einem tutorium wie kann man ein
seminar leiten solche fahrgeschäfte
ich würde dann einfach anfängt wir
kommen ins ohr ein echtes neue kenntlich
im ausland mit seinem publikum umgeht
und alle sind müde
doch nachts um sie zu aktivieren die
situation kennt sicherlich das muss
nicht nur nach tumor gezeigt kann auch
spätabends oder einmal nachmittag mit
aktiv kennt jeder empfehlen sich
verschiedene methoden können ganz
spezielle methoden anwenden zum
aktivierende teilnehmerin der teilnehmer
die idee wie man die teilnehmer
aktivieren können man könnte
beispielsweise sehr laut reden
die möglichkeit genau dann könnte
wichtiger punkt könnte so eine
auflockerung gemacht also einfach die
teilnehmer bitten aufzustehen und
greifen zu bilden sich vielleicht was
tut zu werten dass wir die möglichkeit
oder ein bisschen raum geben einfach ein
bisschen körperbewegungen plastik ja
jetzt nicht so aus in der form bieten
aktuell aktiviert
vielleicht auf dem stand behörde genau
der lösung also zum beispiel damit
bestimmte innerhalb der familie kann
jemand anderen zu gut um der muss dann
irgendeine frage verstehen weil auch
noch so werden die teilnehmer eine
heterogene verhältnis haben also wenn
sie jung und alt
was kein problem die antwort eigentlich
mal im traum denkbar schlechte pflege
sind nicht so problematisch aber bei uns
schon manchmal schwierig sei gericht
eine mitteilung gibt die einfach schon
mehr wissen mitbringen um
teilnehmerinnen kleiner die anpflanzung
ungleichgewicht gibt da kann man zum
beispiel mal ein paar gehoben und teil
und die teilnehmer können profitieren
was noch nicht wissen was sie lernen in
der errichtung der wissensstand ist also
das einfach mal abrufen zurück fragt wo
möglichkeit
oder man könnte zum beispiel dafür
sorgen dass etwas fortgeschritten und
teilnehmer die minister fortgeschritten
ein bisschen helfen dass man so ein
dialog möglich wenn man nimmt eine
diskussion führt und die fragen streiten
konzept angenommen
und dann stellte fragen oder haustier
edition komplett dem einfach das macht
also wie kann man damit umgeht wenn
sozusagen klima gar nicht die frage
einfach nicht gestellt werden
also ich hatte damit gute erfahrungen
machten gehe ich zurück fühle mich das
wirklich ist also mich bedanken können
sie den bezug zu diesem thema ein
bisschen klar beherrschte er hat nämlich
schluss einfach die frage zu geben und
die teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
fördern nochmal genauer fassen
das könnte ja leider doch genau das
passiert sein dass man einfach mehr
anträge antwort
im kopf hat er als seminarleiter und
damit gar nicht die antwort richtig
würdigen kann
das heißt auch um selbst herstellen dass
man offen gelegt ist abweichende
antworten
ok power management ganz wichtiges thema
bevor die sitzung auf die einzelne aber
auch ausgang gemerkt oder gehört wie die
von davor ja also effektiv sicht immer
sich so einen bogen zu machen so richtig
sagt für das gefühl die wollen wir nicht
verteilen ausgang semester gesehen
natürlich optionsschein plan
die will ich in einer einzigen
institution möglichst ausgeglichen
behandeln und freundliches immer
zeitpuffer einzuplanen
folglich braucht man viel zu viel zeit
und kommt es zu dem streit kommt kennt
jeder diskussion zum ausschalten
ascom fragen noch verständnis
verständnisfragen film die noch weitere
fragen aufwerfen immer ständig von der
zeit her dann in zeitnot und deswegen
empfiehlt es sich ganz fest im verein zu
klagen dass um die letzten drei minuten
dafür reserviert um noch einmal die
inhalte sitzung zusammen
kontrolle bildungsverein gesagt
beschluss zur einstellung wir wollen
jetzt mal rekapitulieren das gemeinsame
arbeiten wir uns ganz klar zu sagen auch
wenn wir zum beispiel die rolle des
titels ist natürlich besonders speziell
weil der tutorial die tutorien einer
teils nicht reduzieren da ist der schon
sehr selbstbewusst in seine eigenen
seminare automaten und kulturell sehr
häufig abhängig
das heißt nicht richtiger dozent nicht
richtig autonomen in der gestaltung
seines
minar oder toben angesagt aber natürlich
auch nicht so studentisch wie die
teilnehmer zwischen der kommt vielleicht
auch in loyalitätskonflikte weil er
vielleicht befreundet ist einige teile
oder die kennt oder andere älter sind
genau das kann auch sein dass keine
dieser teilnehmer hat es ganz gut
also tut diese rolle selbst explizit zu
machen sozusagen ist meine aufgabe
vor den teilnehmern also ich möchte
sagen helfen vermitteln zwischen
anfängen und produzenten auf der zur
vermittlung daran dass auch ausdrücklich
wählen um die zuschauer zum beispiel
familien möchten
da liegt nicht an der stapel hier hab
ich also von aixtron tb fälle hat dabei
die kann jeder vor ian erfolgreich
gestalten einen hand und ich zu teuer
ich hab gehört der beschreibung wie die
linke für den büchern
das ist ein sehr empfehlenswertes buch
dann gibt es auch wieder gute gewinne
zweiten auflage ein didaktisch natürlich
leben wir generell nicht mehr tutorien
generell werde aber sehr hilfreich auf
alle fälle fehlen diese fehlen kann dann
ist ein ganz neues neuer trend ist die
digitale hochschullehre da habe ich auch
großen vielleicht nach hinten zu
überspringen damit ist das handbuch
lehre digital einblick in verschiedene
möglichkeiten digitale medien anzubinden
tradition ihrer seminare und wir
steigern uns ganze fluss wichtigste buch
hier grob zu lesen
ein kompendium mit dem attraktiven 90
eine komplexe software entwicklung von
tim k videos nach unten im link einige
beispiele für folgen haben können wir
die oft leicht ausprobieren gibt es zur
letzten frage eigentlich gibt vielleicht
eine app oder der website kino.to
tour.de und darauf hin dass alle
informationen zu dem thema die bedeutung
gesprochen hat man so viel mehr vor
allem zu lehrmethode deaktiviert
studierenden in pflegesituationen wenig
weh tut finde ich viele beispiele habe
ich auch ein link und intrigen in der
beschreibung super dann vielen dank
schaut euch an wenn wir im plan so viel
kostet das lernen